-I had to learn a lot
of dialogue for this movie.
-Yeah, I was gonna say.
-Yes. You can tell.
-There was so much --
Yeah, there was so much under --
-There was, like,
text and subtext.
That's what I liked about it.
-Yeah.
-Now, we should point out,
that is an intense,
incredible fight scene.
It's not the only one.
This is pretty nonstop action
throughout the film.
-Yeah.
-You had some doubts
in the beginning
that you were up
for this kind of fight film.
Is that true?
-Yeah. I mean,
unless you're a fighter,
it's a really difficult thing
to kind of step in
and make believable, right?
And a lot of this film,
the story and the motion
is really told
through this physical action,
and we try to do
some crazy-ass [bleep]
-And you --
you trained with Keanu Reeves.
Is this true?
-I -- Look, I say
a lot of weird [bleep]
and that's
probably not true, either.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-We trained in the same --
We trained in the same facility.
[ Laughter ]
And...I saw him.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-No, actually,
we're really good friends.
We made two movies together.
I've known him
for over 20 years.
He's one of the greatest guys,
and we did train
in the same facility.
-Well, it was funny,
because you didn't think
in the way that you wouldn't
think of yourself
as sort of this
fighting action hero.
Keanu Reeves, in just sort of
recent years as John Wick,
has become
the same sort of incredible,
like, sort of physical actor.
-Yeah.
-So it seems to be
a perfect person to train with.
-Yeah, I mean, I feel like he's
done a couple of action films,
but he's great
in this character.
-Yeah.
-And he was definitely --
It was because he's
a really good friend of mine,
it was good to have him there,
because it's so hard
to train on this level
four or five hours.
-And you did, then,
get injured, right?
Knee? Tooth?
-I was bruised.
I didn't have
any massive injuries,
nothing that would make, like,
a really cool story.
-Were you bummed out?
-I was a little bit.
Like, this story's been running
around the press that,
you know,
I cracked two teeth.
And it just sounds like
somebody, like,
busted me in the face.
But, really,
I just did it myself,
clenching on my own jaw.
-Oh, well, that's --
that's a lot worse.
-It's not as cool, you know?
-"And it was
back at my hotel room and..."
-Yeah.
I wasn't even aware of it.
-"I was watching
'Real Housewives,'
and I saw something
that just freaked me out.
-Were you there?
-I was there, yeah.
-Jesus.
-Your kids --
I know your kids
were around the set.
Were they aware
that their mom was sort of
going out every day
to sort of get waled on?
[ Laughter ]
-That would make me
a terrible mother, wouldn't it?
-Yeah.
[ Laughing ]
-I try not to --
You know,
I try to be responsible.
But there were a few days where
I definitely forgot to not --
you know, to let my mom know
not to bring them around.
-Oh, right.
To set and stuff?
-Yeah, and then
you'll have to --
You know, got to think fast.
And so,
there's been a few times,
you know, when I was like,
"Mommy, had a -- I was painting.
I had a paint party."
-[ Laughing ]
-"And I got some paint
on my face and my clothes."
-Right.
"A lot of, uh, red paint.
I was painting a barn.
Mommy was painting a barn."
[ Laughter ]
-Things like that, yeah.
-This takes place in 1989,
in Berlin.
-Five days before the Wall falls
in Berlin, yes.
-And yet the villains are
sort of the Russians and KGB,
so works out really well.
Very great branding
for the film.
-Sounds so far-fetched,
doesn't it?
But you had to learn
some Russian.
How's your Russian?
-Terrible.
-Is it really bad?
-Yeah.
-How do you say "terrible"
in Russian?
-I don't have a clue.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Russian accent ] "Terrible."
[ Normal voice]
I think that's it.
-Oh, God. Oh, yeah.
-How much did you have to learn?
Or, how many lines
did you have in Russian?
-Well, we had -- we had very
specific scenes that I learned.
Then, we got there,
and then we did a rewrite,
and then I had to relearn
different lines,
and it was just --
it's a really
difficult language to learn
without drinking tons of vodka.
-Yeah.
-Which I couldn't do,
'cause I had to fight a lot,
so I had to stay sober for --
-I bet there are some Russians
who drink vodka and then fight.
[ Laughter ]
I bet they don't let that
get in the way.
A couple.
There's one or two, I'm sure.